jaquelin balake d nice a-a-ron it's
pronounced aaron insubordinate and
churlish
okay students settle down
settle down
that includes you mr rodriguez
do you want to take the milk carton off
of your head
thank you so much
we have a special guest today
he's from this neighborhood
and he's a former gang member
he's coming here this morning
to talk to you about life choices
so please give a warm central high
school welcome to donnie herrera
[Applause]
i used to be just like you
just like you you you you
used to clown around
make fun of the principal
put milk on my head just like you
rodriguez
then
i got hit with aids
consequences
got into some real trouble
boy
stole from my mom and dad
stole from my own sister
and then one day
a piano fell on my head what
consequences
i feel like you missed a step there gave
me 88 concussions
one for each key
you think i'm learning but no
see i'm just like you
i got back out there started making some
real crimes home boy
oh yeah
oh yeah
and then
i got trampled by a herd of buffalo what
consequences
okay donnie um i think we've had enough
done with my story
i was like you
i decided it'd be cool
to hang out with some of the tough kids
you know who i'm talking about they were
hanging on the streets late at night
more than cigarette smokers homes
and then
one day
i got shot out of a catapult that's it
okay into the mouth of a dragon students
everything you've heard here today is a
lie i don't lie anymore you're all
excused
look at me
i shouldn't even be here thank you
i apologize so i got really deep into
crimes i did a drive-by at my own
daughter's quinceanera
yeah
shut up everybody dead killed
yeah
yeah
then i got sucked into a wormhole
consequences that's it okay everybody go
i was in another dimension tried to
introduce my own parents to each other
almost failed arm was disappearing
i invented johnny be good at my parents
prom and at the last moment they kissed
and it came back the faster we get away
from him the better nobody believe me
where's my crack when my crack
all right listen up y'all
i'm your substitute teacher mr garvey i
taught school for 20 years in the inner
city
so don't even think about messing with
me
y'all feel me
mm-hmm okay let's take a roll here
jay quellon
where's jay quillinette
no jay quellon here
yeah
uh do you mean jacqueline
okay
so that's how it's to be y'all want to
play
okay then
i've got my eye on you jquery
but lockheed
where is bolaque at
just no blocker here today
yes sir
my name is blake
are you out of your goddamn mind
blake
what do you want to go to war malaki no
cause we could go to war no i'm for real
i'm for real
so you better check yourself
d nice
is there a d nice
if one of y'all
says some silly ass name
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath
now d nice
do you mean denise son of a [ __ ]
you say your name right right now denise
say it right denise correctly denise
right denise right
d nice that's better thank you now
a-a-ron
where are you
where is a-a-ron right now
no a-a-ron huh
well you better be sick
dead or mute a-a-ron here oh man
why didn't you ask me the first time i
said it huh huh i'm just you know i'm
just asking you know i said it like four
times so why didn't you say it the first
time i said a-a-ron
because it's pronounced aaron simon
you done messed up a ron now take your
ass on down to osak hennessy's office
right now and tell him exactly what you
did
who oh shag hennessy
principal o'shaughnessy get out of my
goddamn classroom before i break my foot
off in your ass insubordinate
and turlish
timothy
present
thank you
i'm gonna take a little roll here
jay quellan
here
you are present blocky
right here uh-huh
d-nice
here
good
jessica
thank you
mr garvey
what is a.a ron some of us need to leave
uh a few minutes early today
oh
oh is that so um and what
pray tell
is the reason
for this premature exodus
yearbook photos
um
we have to leave 15 minutes early to
meet up with our clubs
all right you know what that might work
with other substitute teachers but i
taught in the inner city for over 20
years
now y'all
want to leave my class early so y'all
can go meet up at the club
ain't none of y'all old enough to go to
the damn club
ridiculous
mr garvey god son of a [ __ ]
did us
doctor just then yes
i'm gonna throw you out the goddamn
window
what jay quinlan mr garvey we're telling
the truth we we have clubs at this
school we have clubs for special
interests okay i see so y'all want to
play y'all want to play yeah okay we're
going to play little games fine i'll
play
i'm more than happy to play some games
with y'all anyone who's in a club
stand your ass up
uh-huh oh yeah there it is there it is
the usual suspects what the hell club
are you in jaquelin
future leaders of america
okay okay
how would you know
if you're gonna be a leader
in the future is there a stargate
in your bedroom can you travel through
town jay kwellen no just sit the flip
down
but like i don't here's the thing i
don't even know why i'm about to ask you
this
but lockheed
what club are you in uh i'm part of the
spanish club sp this
you about as spanish as rion seacrest
with your big-ass fraggle rock hair
how about you d nice i'm in the chess
club
uh i'm sorry sweetheart you are
not in the emphasis
the mosquito bite club maybe oh it's
hurtful truthful
there he is
hey ron hey
what club
are you in
i'm the president of the glee club why
do i talk the glee club
like they gonna have a club
dedicated to a tv show take your ass to
osha hennessy's office right now before
i bust a club up in your butt okay
no okay here you go
mischievous and deceitful chicanerous
and deplorable
this is principal o'shaughnessy students
please report to the gymnasium for your
club photos fake announcement
now does anybody in here
have a valid reason for leaving this
classroom
timothy i got to go pick up my daughter
your excuse
mrs brown is like the most lesbo teacher
i've ever seen in my life cleaning over
me
[Music]
why you reading [ __ ]
because i like to read and this is a
really good book you're a really good
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
why you got to bother me man
because
i'm not doing very well at school i'm
reading at a third grade level i really
don't want to get left back so when i
see somebody reading for fun
it makes me feel that much more stupid
and then i get mad
[Music]
um i didn't know that
thanks so much for opening up to me shut
up queer
i understand why i mean why you got to
go there
i've been having sexual fantasies about
some of the other guys at school give me
that
i'm afraid of these feelings and what
they might mean it's like because i hate
myself so much i gotta point that hate
outward towards you
[Music]
you understand this on such a deep level
that i don't know
now i'm going to punish you physically
for acknowledging my emotional problems
i was going to say if you understand
yourself so well then maybe you should
try working on changing it of course i
want to change it
but it's the only defense mechanism i
have against deeper more terrifying
problems buried inside of me
lucky my dad's here
get the damn talk son i need to take you
home and beat on you because i hate
myself and you look like your mother who
left me
and i'ma block out the guilt i feel over
mistreating you with the river of vodka
[Music]
i'm gonna internalize that and
unknowingly transfer it onto you
tomorrow
[Music]
coming reluctantly
[Music]
yeah you going to rey's party
yeah i'm going you know amy's gonna be
there
yeah i know things have been real good
with her man tonight could be the night
it could be
dude
you okay
not really dude
what's wrong you're the hottest girl at
a party with no parrots you're
definitely gonna hit that for sure
tonight man you're gonna lose that v for
good
my penis is white
excuse me
i have
a white
penis what but you're black
no oh
i'm biracial
all the white went straight to my penis
but what what you mean like like the the
color
oh
yeah but wait
dude i mean
how bad could it be uh
how bad it's like a snickers
regular or fun size
which one do you get at halloween
a fun size that's the one
i know
what am i gonna do i mean i
how am i gonna hit it with amy with my
little white penis
everyone's gonna find out and i'm never
gonna hear the end of it dude amy's
white
she's not gonna care
really yeah
she's white
yeah
i guess you're right
she's probably not even gonna know the
difference ah man white girl white penis
you're all good
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there he is how'd it go last night
don't want to talk about it well what
happened black
vagina
[Music]
the right triangle's longest side is
called the hypotenuse
and it's this side here let's see the
longest one i wish i were high on
hotness
i wish i was high on pot noose
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay okay okay
mr morrison's very funny it's very funny
but let's get back to the lesson
if you can see the longest one where it
goes from this point that was my joke
i know man that was hilarious of a
triangle i've labeled them here a b and
c no but
i said that please
please mr jackson keep your comments to
yourself
thank you
ah now the hypotenuse
[Laughter]
you really got me on that one oh so
great oh oh principal martel principal
martel come here come here come here uh
tell principal martel what you said troy
oh uh
um she was talking about the hypotenuse
and i said i wish i was high on pot
noose
[Applause]
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
he likes it
principal martel is cool
that's a very funny principle martel
principal martel i said that mr jackson
that is enough what i said at first
oh uh mr iglesias mr iglesias yes come
in come in
yeah
what's up people's fluffy
comedian giveaway iglesias is touring
the local schools today for a charity
he's working on tell him what you said
tell me what you said
oh
i wish i was high on pot noose
oh my god that is clever that is good
very funny really funny
mr iglesias mr iglesias uh i'm your
biggest fan that was my joke uh you know
it's not really cool buddy to take
credit for other people's jokes
hey listen
funny stuff i'm doing this big tour
right now you want to see about maybe we
could talk about your opening i need an
opener
oh
um sure
what do you think is that okay of course
what
sorry about that hey
nice to meet you thanks so much richard
pryor get over here man come on
he deserved it
all right so across from the longest
side is a 90 degree angle
good thing i've got a 90 degree dangle
yo stop it you will never be troy
why are you trying to be like troy
dick
a two nerdy girl
so
the hypotenute
right here
oh my god
[Music]
i
am your substitute
mr nostrom
but that might as well say no nonsense
because i do not
play
now today will not be a day off
in fact today you will work harder than
somebody called
okay
all right everybody just uh let's settle
down
settle in and like just totally let's
get our math on okay
all right guys so um
all right
somebody's got a little extra energy
from phys ed right
jimmy buddy hey buddy let's okay let's
just let's knock it off okay
okay
you got me he got me right guys
jimmy dude all right let's take our seat
that's great bounce free
that's great
very good bravo jeremy i'm just kidding
you guys can clap
[Applause]
that was awesome oh and i thank you i
thank you for the entertainment man
[Music]
come on let's go man hey buddy
i don't want to harsh your vibe man but
ah
eureka i'm gonna be honest with you
really pushing my buttons now jimmy
driving me
[Music]
crazy you want me to write your name on
the board
[Applause]
okay jimmy do you want me to call
principal martel
that would not be bitching would it
you know what timmy you know what why
don't you come up and teach the class
man
hmm
wouldn't that be awesome
[Laughter]
no and then you know what i'm going to
do jimmy i'll just sit here how about
that jimmy and then we can all watch how
you're being disrupted
oh i see that's supposed to be me
right
all right jimmy okay i see that i get it
supposed to be me it's time to be done
jimmy don't you dare johnny
[Laughter]
well this is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um
[Laughter]
give me five give me five
huh how about that huh that's you jimmy
i'm jimmy
i'm jimmy
and i need attention yeah i'm jenny
i'm jimmy hello look at that i'm gonna
be happy that's the funniest thing that
ever happened
i'm jimmy i want attention wiggy
mr flyer
principal martel no what no no no no no
it was jimmy it was jimmy principal
martel no jeffy why it was jenny
it was jimmy
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]